[Music]
joining me this week is an author a
journalist and a commentator on the
rebel TV lauren southern welcome to the
rubin report thanks for having me
we are way overdue for the yeah there's
been a lot of comments on twitter yeah
constantly when you going on ribbon when
you're going on reuben so people are
probably gonna be pretty estatic to see
this they are already ecstatic you have
to do what Twitter demands and of course
more find that today but oh god say yeah
you happy now you are coming we're here
in LA but you know yesterday I guess
we're in Mexico yeah an anarchist
convention yeah it's called an orca poco
so a bunch of hippies bunch of antique
status you had people like Adam Koch ash
there and Jeff Berwick all these
lucrative ski I was it was a lot of fun
of course every table I sat down at they
look at me are you uh status you know
but I I think we agree on more than we
disagree so I had fun there yeah so
we've only met once and it almost seems
like a lifetime ago
you joined Milo when he came on my show
the first time which I think was it was
either October or November of 2015 so
it's not that long ago but that seems
like a lifetime ago doesn't it yeah it
was October and we went to the Amber
Rose SlutWalk then oh my gosh it does
feel like so long ago
Milo blew up since then like insanely
I've been I started working at rebel
full-time that was crazy just met you
briefly there but you're in a completely
different studio yeah so I do want to
talk about your rise but let's talk
about Milo for just sure cuz if you
mentioned his name and then you don't
say something everyone's gonna freak out
what are your general thoughts on what's
happened over the last couple weeks you
know I actually made a video on it and
then I just decided not to publish it
because I didn't think I could be
objective on it because I know like I
lived with Milo for like a week when I
was in LA with him and we went to your
show and talked to him a bit obviously
he's been such a good person to me
personally he's even helped me through
stuff like in my personal life like he's
been just such a kind person he is not a
pedophile he doesn't support pedophilia
I will never believe that however I
understand how people look
in on the situation reacted that way and
I understand how I would have reacted if
it were a Democrat that did this me
knowing Milo personally changes my
opinion on the issue but I can't I can't
blame people for criticizing him so I I
didn't publish the video because I
didn't think I could be objective yeah
it's not one of the tough things of
being sort of an online person is that
you feel like you have to comment on
everything and in this case you're
actually friends with the person and
it's like no matter what you say a
certain amount of people are gonna be
angry at you for it yeah yeah it was it
was it was tough to watch it was tough
to watch because it was so as much as it
was true like true these were quotes
that were yeah he had said they came out
of his area it was obviously something
that was coordinated to get him to not
speak at CPAC obviously something
coordinated from the right which was
even more crazy to me to take him down
so I mean it's hard to not take that
into consideration when thinking about
it as well
and I always that's what worried me too
I thought about what if I get to the
size that Milo is one day what if I have
two million Facebook followers one day
and people go back and they just rummage
through the stuff that I've done what
would they find and you know I thought
about this one video I did in high
school it was for a grade 12 history
project and a girl friend and I dressed
up as Hitler and Mussolini when we sing
to it yeah I've got war crimes that we
did and like we got an a-plus on it put
[ __ ] someone found that video yeah and
took it out of context like the stuff
that they can do to you if you have a
deranged coordinated attack against you
horrifying so is this just a very slick
move by you just mentioning this video
right now because now you know what I
mean you beat them to the punch that's
tonight like eight mile you know you got
a self dog see yeah get there first so
you said it's very obviously a
coordinated something now my feeling on
conspiracy theories I always say
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence I assume you
don't have any evidence that it was
nominated by someone on the right I
gotta say I've talked to people that I I
can't say much without revealing much
but I've talked people who like know
some of the people that were like kind
of involved and knew what was happening
beforehand so
I obviously I can't substantiate that so
I don't expect anyone to believe me
that's just personal
I guess there's tons of people watching
this is gonna be so okay so without
getting into the specifics of the
evidence why would somebody on the right
I mean Milo was becoming the
counterculture thing that was making
conservatism cool again why would they
want to take him out well Milo threatens
the people
Milo Trump the kind of
anti-establishment type right that want
to bring the right back to what
conservatism actually is and not
neo-cons not kind of the like
establishment people the people want to
bring it back to its origins are the big
threat to the ebon McMuffins of the
world the evan McMuffins is he is he
really someone that's in power though
not really really but you mean those the
ideas of those yeah exactly
yeah what do you make of Trump in that
regard do you think he really is a
conservative I mean that's why I think
everything's so crazy right now you got
the left and right fighting but Trump
doesn't really exist in either of those
spaces well I think our political
spectrum of left to right is a little
outdated we and it's really been it's
it's to simplify things for the wider
populace you don't pay attention to
politics that much who aren't going to
look at every policy they it's just easy
categorization left right
whereas I mean you have Trump coming out
and I don't agree with this but he's
going and putting out policies like
supporting women in science and this
kind of staff MS like oh that's kind of
a lefty thing to do right and like the
his views on health care and a lot of
there's there's there are people in this
world that are have have pieces of the
left and the right and mix them together
in their politics and I think Trump is
far more one of those people than a lot
of the other people these are that
pretty much we all are except that
everyone keeps yelling if anyone
deviates in their thought but we all are
complex and have inconsistencies and
have pieces that might feel a little
more left or a little more people people
need categorization in order to
understand things I I always
a problem with using the word the left
to describe people I mean I grew up
listening to people like Ann Coulter and
Dennis Prager and they used the word the
left a lot but then I'd listen to people
like sargon of akkad and they're like
I'm I'm a classical liberal right it's
like what do I want to use the word the
left to describe everything but when you
do more and more videos online you kind
of realize it works you get more views
more people pay attention because they
understand that that's already when you
I don't blame people for not being
totally engaged in politics all the time
if they have jobs they have families
take care of they have realized yeah a
good government would be one that we
don't have to talk about all the time
so they people need things to be a
little like compartmentalized so that
wider society can understand what's
going on so when you say the left more
people kind of understand what you're
talking about now of course if you say
that in a political science classroom
the professor's gonna be like what are
you talking about
elaborate right right so before we get
too deep into all the political stage
tell me a little bit about your history
like what even got you involved into
politics were you always into politics
oh well yeah I've been into politics
since I was a kid I think he recently
had Dennis Prager on the show my dad
used to listen to Dennis Prager all the
time when he would drive me to school
this is when I was like 13 and you'd be
driving us to school and I'd love
listening to Dennis Prager in the
background super interesting was the
opposite of what I was hearing in the
classroom all the time so it made me a
very kind of anti-authority kid because
I'd always be like but what about this
but what about that and all my
presentations would be auntie what the
teachers wouldn't say cuz I just had so
much fun with it how did that go for a
kid in school in Canada I not so well I
mean a lot of bad you know get kicked
out of classes kind of situation I was I
was a definitely a a or D students like
I do very good in the classes that I
loved but if I didn't get along with the
teacher like F D student right yeah but
yeah it was kind of that I started
downloading the Dennis Prager podcasts
on my own and listening to them but one
thing I will say is I never had my views
forced on me growing up it was always my
dad I would come home from school and I
would learn something at school or
whatever and I
tell my dad about it whether it be
privilege theory or about kind of the
history of Canada and how White's were
oppressive to natives or something and
he would just ask me questions he would
never say no this is you should have
this right-wing opinion he would be like
okay I need it's for example do you
think that they had war and fights here
before the settlers came to Canada do
you think that happened Lauren do you
think it was a black-and-white situation
and I kind of sit there and think to
myself I don't know when I'd look into
it on my own right he just asked me
questions and whatever the better
argument was that I'd find was what I
would go with and if that argument was
debunked one day that's what I would go
with later right so that was a very I
had a very good childhood very good
parenting I'd say and that my dad's
interest in politics and him always
questioning me led me to take political
sciences when I went to university were
you political science major I was but I
dropped out it's a waste of money oh you
dropped out of school yeah I went to go
major in political science did like two
years and then I was like peace yeah I
pay anymore for this I can learn on my
own I thought you were gonna say that
you had graduated as a Poli Sci major
which would have made the two of us the
only two people that ever use that
degree - Poli Sci philosophy all of its
barista degrees Yeah right so do you
consider yourself a conservative again
you know this has been a through line
through all my shows with the labels and
we've already addressed that but they
don't quite make sense but you strike me
a little more as a libertarian and I
guess as you just said the anarchists
will consider you a status but but what
do you really consider yourself putting
a label on it so hard national
capitalist libertarian nationalist
but that's the thing - libertarians I am
a conservative to conservatives I'm more
libertarian yeah what do we need to know
about Canada just the politics of Canada
because I feel like we know nothing
about Canada we see Trudeau and he's
smiling or he's on the mosque floor with
the men half mocking that the women are
segregated and some other things but
what do we need to know about him
sure don't quite literally got elected
because of his hair like and because
there was nepotism because of his father
and his father who his father was and
most people within the Canadian
government that worked for Trudeau I
mean I I'm not too much into the
politicians or puppets conspiracy
Trudeau is literally a puppet like he's
like they they just made him a leader
because they knew he would win because
of his pretty face and because of his
father and then they all think he's a
joke so that's Canada right now we are
being led by a literal joke that is a
joke to his own party and I would I'd
say to everyone who likes Liberty is
look at looking to Maxine Bernier he is
a french-canadian candidate that is
literally a libertarian running for the
Conservative Party right now and I think
he has a real shot at winning he is the
most campaign donations of any of the
candidates running right now and he's
like a literal Rand Paul imagine if Rand
Paul had the highest campaign donations
in the American election that would be
crazy so he's been a fun to watch a few
okay candidates know Trump's Kevin
O'Leary is not Trump is he not that's
where I was going next he's not Trump no
he's a he makes lots of comments vote
and anti-gun comments Pro refugee
comments very very globalist Paul so
you'll have to I don't have it all on me
right now my coworker faith Goldie she
she's done a really good video talking
about this and why she doesn't think
kevin O'Leary is Trump yeah so in a way
he'd be too centrist to sort of capture
the imagination the way Trump did down
here yeah yeah and I mean we've got a
lot of politicians in Canada trying to
be Trump right now we have this one lady
Kelly leach and she she is the one who's
been in the news lately cuz she came out
with a immigration test where she wants
to test for Canadian values and everyone
was like wow is this our Trump like she
has a real extent on immigration and
making sure people assimilate but then
she does this ridiculous stuff like she
sent out an email and in the bottom of
it it's like we need to drain the canal
is like trying is so hard she's just
she's not Trump we have to put 18 on the
something-or-other of the country
they're trying very very hard to emulate
what happened
and then you've got another half of them
that are trying very very hard to not
and condemn it and call it white
supremacy there's this guy named Michael
Chong who was quite literally he's just
a liberal that's running for the
Conservatives and why do we we called
Marc John Kasich and he's just calling
everything white supremacy supporting
all the big liberal policies and all of
the politicians that are like Trump he's
calling out so the whole Canadian
election is kind of being based around
the American election right now and
people either not wanting to be like
that or wanting to be like that well
good luck with all of that thank you we
need it what do you make of the whole
white supremacy thing the idea that we
even have to talk about this seems sort
of ridiculous
I just don't think yes I think there are
some white supremacist as there always
have been I don't think that there are
Nazis running around Nazis were a
political party in Germany in the 1930s
they're not really running around but
this idea that somehow white supremacism
has come back and it's conflated with
Pepe memes and all that stuff like what
portion of this do you actually think is
is real and has traction
well effective matter is that people
literally have to create white supremacy
they are so desperate to find it that
they are making fake swastikas they are
pointing out what if someone's just
wearing a white hat that's a Klan hood
right I in fact the the Canadian Nazi
Party in Canada my boss Ezra did a good
video on it there was actually a Jewish
organization that backed up and egged on
people to start the Canadian Nazi Party
because they wanted more like kind of
hate crimes to point out right right and
it's so it's sort of like the cops need
a certain amount of crime a certain
political view you need these hate
groups otherwise yeah I don't have
anything yeah and like half the people
on sites like Stormfront
are feds like it's it's a big joke
online if you go I spent a lot of time
like in tons of different political
communities on Facebook just like
reading it and if you go into any
alt-right Facebook groups the joke is
always if you post anything super Nazi
or anything they're like Oh fed are you
a Fed right anyway they're like no one
does that in real life no one runs
around with Nazi tattoos in real life
you don't see it so if it doesn't exist
then what well you know you would have
agree that some of it exists right like
there's something there
somewhere that's yeah even even the
Richard Spencer's of the world like
their their miss their even them they're
kind of misrepresented as well like
Richard Spencer is not a white
supremacist he is a white nationalist he
believes in a white ethno state he
doesn't believe in whites being superior
so the problem that's happened is so
many people I have they've never read
fascist literature they've never studied
any of the far-right ideologies they've
just been pulled bigotry bigotry bigotry
repeat bigotry so they have no idea what
they're talking about so either there
now they've gone in they called
everything Nazism everything white
supremacy the word means nothing anymore
and then when you have Richard Spencer's
come out of the woodwork that supports a
white ethno state kind of thing they
don't even know how to argue against him
because they've never even heard the
arguments in their life before the only
argument they have is bigoted so if
there is a white nationalist white
supremacist uprising in America it's
simply going to be because the arguments
against white nationalists don't exist
other than bigoted either they'll hear
that punch nuts
exactly and that's not a good argument
and it's literally bringing sympathy to
the very very few people that exist
[Music]
you
[Music]